agnès brawn vient d'enterrer son mari
elle élève seule ses sept enfants
pourtant ce film est une comédie la vie
est dure sur le marché de dublin one yet
vend des fruits et légumes mais il ya là
marion sa meilleure amie et toutes les
copines de wall street
agnès bron est une histoire de femmes
d'amitié et de solidarité
ce film est tiré d'un roman de manet qui
avait été un succès en irlande il ya
cinq ans j'ai beaucoup aimé ce type de
relation entre fall l'entr'aide l'amour
c'est un sujet qui s'adapte bien au
cinéma ce genre de relation entre les
jours fendi la salle maxi mégane est
possible
il y a aussi le méchant bilicki raquette
sur le marché mais agnès résiste à tout
le monde et surtout elle rêve comme une
midinette
son rêve c'est de voir un jour un
concert de tom jones tom jones qui joue
son propre rôle dans le film il joue le
rôle très masculin de la bonne façon
je pense qu'il a bien aimé jouer dans ce
film que cela lui a plu
anjelica huston a mis tout son coeur
dans ce film tourné à dublin où elle a
grandi jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans et tout
son talent dans ce personnage attachant
de mère courage dans l'irlande des
années 60